yeah what's your question I'm just going
to talk about how I see I seen you on my
Instagram all the time your podcast
Clips okay all your YouTube videos and
I've seen tons of your videos when I
think that's a stupid question
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
another awesome episode of the careful
boys where we are off the Record and
today we have Mr Jimmy Zhang in the
building y'all
you know what's so funny about uh my
like I guess semi relationship with
Jimmy is I had a relationship with him
um and a friendship with Jimmy without
knowing
it was all imaginary
feel free to not elaborate okay so so so
so how do you feel about that Jimmy so
so because it came in a dream one
uh we have mutual friends
so I've heard about you
two I have a feeling you came somehow
and you met you know JK members yeah
right yeah and then so so because of all
this I thought I already met you in
person and when we chat on video chat
you're like oh nice to finally meet you
and I'm all like what are you talking
about we've been yeah yeah we've been
yeah right I've been friends I've known
you and I was like wait were you ever in
a JK Party video no I don't think I've
been any anything well you've been to
that office
the LA one or you met JK peoples I think
I just met JK people like like Julia
Josh that's what okay that's what I'm
okay yeah yeah because I couldn't make
it to that day for some reason when you
guys all hung out and stuff but because
of that I've heard I've heard you know
your name and then like people like um
uh Chris uh uh uh Frugal Aesthetics yes
yeah like people that have known you
know and hung out with you I just felt
like we were already friends and somehow
my head was like yeah I already hung out
with this dude we're already friends but
you just made it all up I made it all up
completely dude well technically I've
been friends with y'all since like 16
because when I was started watching you
guys oh wow so so I actually been
friends with you guys you guys didn't
know how old are you now oh
[Laughter]
right because it's like when I was
watching you guys I was in high school
and now time skip right now I'm here wow
yeah yeah yeah how do you know him
um well you introduced me but I've seen
you in videos with Larry yes yes I think
I have a similar feeling with you where
I'm like I don't know you know you but I
feel like we know enough of the same
people or it feels familiar right were
you working out with Larry at barbell
yeah a couple times couple times yeah
yeah I was in barbell do you know be
sick since like nobody actually knows
you if we like got to know you right now
questions yeah yeah that's probably
their question what's your question yeah
what's your question I'm just going to
talk about how I I seen you on my
Instagram all the time your podcast
Clips okay all your YouTube videos and
I've seen tons of your videos I think
you're funny that's a stupid question
what's your what's your podcast name oh
down bad show that's the one you seen
yeah I'll ask you a real question okay
it's gonna be a real question it's a
real question get ready I'm ready let's
say your mom comes into the room your
room right and then you're jacking off
yeah and then and then you're you're you
don't want to show their mom and then so
how do you make a story up that's an
excuse explaining why you just [__]
into like a shoe or something
oh so I have the shoe under the blankets
because usually if I'm I'm jacking off
how do you do it how do you do it okay
that's the question I'm doing it while
my mom is downstairs knowingly my mom is
downstairs I will do it with blankets
over me why right it's true that way huh
why that way I think he's trying to
cover his face
yeah I see yeah I'm not right if my mom
isn't downstairs then I'm I'm open yeah
okay so she comes inside she goes hey
Jimmy what are you doing underneath that
nice blanket Jimmy why are you touching
a Jimmy yeah I'm I'm itchy mom um yeah
just really simple is that a temple
no yes
that's a good question right thank you
Barbara yeah my question was stupid
facing the door if the door is right
here
I'm I'm this way right the the blankets
this way the door's right here right now
[Laughter]
in my
mom's fall asleep right away yeah that's
a good one actually yeah that's
underrated okay okay
you said my questions suck yours I said
you give me
[Laughter]
yeah dude I think I knew you but we
didn't know each other yeah I think I
knew it but we didn't know each other
I'm like dude what the [__] are we
talking about here dude let's just
[__] talk to the guy
I'm like I didn't know you where are you
from like New York New York originally
okay so so here's the thing I did see
your name on the call sheet and I was
like who is this guy and I'm like I'm
hosting this so I gotta like look up
[__] and of course the very first thing
is I see you're taking like an adult
Entertainer out there dating like [__] I
gotta watch This I Gotta watch this
YouTube video that was such a great
video yeah and then it wasn't just
I was like damn it was really
interesting so I had to look you up on
YouTube and I watched the whole [__]
video and I'm like holy [__] was that
was that a a straight up date did it
happen organically or was it like a I'ma
put you an idea and let's see if you're
down no the the one with Angela was just
me walking into that convention that day
with the idea of taking Like a Porn Star
out on to dinner yeah um because earlier
before I went in I just got a
reservation I know boo hoping praying
that you know somebody would say yes
well you're smart and uh well is it the
Vegas no boo no it this one is in
Chicago oh yeah
um so I walked in and I kind of pitched
a couple of porn stars but they were
yeah I just grabbed a couple numbers
right yeah but then you know there was a
line there was a Brazzers line now you
guys are familiar with browsers never
heard of it dude never what is that yeah
what is that do they make cheese
do they make cheese laughed or something
Security Board yeah they make
Philadelphia cream cheese
you guys probably have Partners at home
watching this so I'm not gonna get you
all in trouble but long lines I have the
uh 14.99 plan oh yeah
[Laughter]
there's a yeah it was just like long
lines and I'm curious like yo if I'm
able to take anybody out why do I take
the most part like why do I at least try
to take out you know just the the most
popular stars there yeah uh and
naturally I you know I saw the line I'm
like [__] this line
um I just try to like talk to like some
of the managers and like the the
assistance first I like Smooth you away
a little bit Yeah Yeah to see if I could
get some light conversations in and then
you know naturally that just came to
like just me chilling in the browser's
booth wow and after you know uh Angela
finished signing I just
yeah I just talked to her just you know
I had got her on a quick little
interview and then pitched like it yo
you must be hungry you've been signing
all day right you have not you know you
haven't even ate like since I've been
here you haven't even eaten yet so I got
this dinner no reservation Nobu why
don't you come with
and then she said um
it was like such an innocent video as
porny as it is the way that he executed
it it was just it was so wholesome yeah
I had MapleStory music
[Laughter]
the porn stuff too because it was just
like yo they hungry too yeah
that was your goal right they like no
Boo too right right I thought it was
funny though because um wait did you
have a camera person at the yes but then
when you left you did it you record it
on your own right yeah yeah yeah yeah
so did you ever jack off to her before
you you know what I did it which I
didn't but you just knew that she's a
big star yes which I think made it a
little bit easier and less uh
nerve-wracking yeah when I first like
spoke to her because there are a couple
stars that I have beat my meat too and I
nervous nerves like you know because
you're like I want to put [__] on you
like I imagined
in those words exactly that's why I hope
I never meet Keanu Reeves
come on dude if Songhai Lee right now
showed up I think all of us would go
freak out I think I would have to go to
like those that type of convention with
those police Shields that way if I come
I don't come on there what a considerate
guy dude yeah I like how you're you're
there naked with just the police Shield
nice to meet you so you don't come on
holy shield with your dick in your hands
yeah you just
riot police Shield
okay wow he's so considerate wow they're
like chivalry is not dead or else
someone else is just spilling and [__]
I'm not like that creep it's good you
think ahead yeah yeah
we don't get much girls on this [__]
show
as you can tell dude no no no Ryan's
Shields are a great assignment okay did
you guys end up doing the Hocus Pocus
out there
what a surprise
um
not that night no no but you did it
later
that's cool man hey can we get around
pause for Jimmy please thank you it was
very suggestive in the end of your
YouTube video that's for sure yeah yeah
I feel like you know Cliffhangers are
great because fingers are great let's go
for it so again again I I apologize I
still don't know that much about you but
I just watched this video uh but like
what what would you say
um
I guess other than the party let's
rewind back what do you do like where
did you where did you start what's your
origin of stuff rewind back time yeah
yeah what got you into creating YouTube
videos yeah yeah yeah well I would
rewind back like two three years for
like before porn stars that was just
when I was making videos about anime and
I was just on the street doing Street
interviews uh because it was just funny
that's what I remember your content
right yeah you had me at anime what kind
of interviews do you do you so it
started off pretty wholesome I was
talking about like just get getting our
uh Asian Americans just you know getting
our ass whooped growing up so I took
like relatable topics that we all talked
about and then but I just like have
conversations with just strangers on the
street about it I think it was like a
new way to deliver that that kind of
Comedy right when it's just like banter
with strangers
um and then that kind of started turning
uh not safe for work just because I'm
I'm I don't know I'm a horny guy yeah
yeah yeah I'm a horny guy how dare you
be horny
and uh horny people are human too yeah
you would say that Anthony Lee
he has the most sex out of all of us
but anyways
you had me at anime right so I also did
did certain uh anime topics
um it wasn't even topics it was like
skits it was uh just [__] with people
in public so you've seen Naruto I
imagine right so we one video I did was
just I had a whole group of friends just
like in like akasi close and we just
just ran around New York City [__]
with people respectfully how many people
are these cloaks we had we had like 10
we had the full so that's like the full
full Clan yeah yeah we had to focus [__]
from pain all the way down to you know
uh uh uh uh Toby yeah all the way to
tell me yeah with the mask with the mask
all right we're getting for all the
people that don't know what a cloak is
what is a cloak closely cloak coke uh
he's basically just referencing in like
one of the most popular animes of all
time Naruto there's like Dragon Ball Z
or something one of the most popular but
yes Naruto is definitely up there and in
conversation
um the Akatsuki Clan is basically like
the evil clan that has all these black
and red cloaks with clouds on them
that's the pattern that I see yeah I see
that yeah he's saying to him and a bunch
of his homies like in in 10 cloaks were
going around New York City we're doing
the run during the [__] Naruto doing
the Run we we also made it very like I
threw so much VFX on it where it made it
less cringy than it sounds
it does sound a little cringy but it
also sounds cool but I'm a fan so
whatever yeah we're all losers on
YouTube so we know what we're doing
retards
and so you started doing that and then
how did it transition into having a
podcast or no I mean uh because I was
also just having like I was just making
videos like whatever I liked you know
just the anime I like anime I you know
related to Asian [__] I'm horny you know
I talk about sex so it's just whatever I
liked I'm I I'm just picturing how do I
make you know my Lane of videos to yo if
you love anime and you and you're horny
you love sex usually that does go into a
quite a bit diagram it's called hentai
yeah a little bit but you know you know
YouTube doesn't really it's it's not
like the old like the good old days when
you could just slap click bait and
titties on a thumbnail I can't even do
that anymore you can't you can't now you
got to go to conventions to get porn
stars go on dates with you yeah you
gotta blur [__] you yeah it's it's so
now I gotta ask the Asian question
because it always happens of course uh
for you I'm assuming like you have
traditional Asian parents yeah that
probably had a set path for you how do
they feel for you to go oh I'm Gonna Go
My Own route this way I have a passion
in interviewing porn stars so originally
I uh I wasn't even born here yeah we
immigrated here uh when I was six
um so they were very much so like fresh
off the boat mentality yeah and they
wanted me to to go into engineering and
architecture because I was like I like
playing with Legos growing up
um
but you know I Envision parents.com they
take you to the most serious serious
[__] like oh what's this money oh you
want to be a banker I just look at that
[__]
is that okay
choosing the next pathway [__] I just
want to touch you can't touch nothing I
just want to sign yeah oh you're gonna
invent the desk one day
they got a [__] kid going to the
guitar and they're like [__] no [__] no
put a violin there instead
um but but yeah I think uh just just uh
so because of that they just instilled
just so much like engineering yeah yeah
I I tried civil engineering engine
Engineering in high school I get to pick
a major in high school oh wow yeah
because I was like a in a specialized
high school they made me take tests for
it it's just yeah uh once I got in I I
sucked I I was just such a like C Plus
student uh I just
did not care I couldn't care less I was
I was in class playing Yu-Gi-Oh I was I
was there was like these uh it's called
Dueling Network I know I know okay
well he knows too probably why what is
this he doesn't know you yeah but he
knows a lot of other Gamers Final
Fantasy anything and he'll know
everything it's like card game like 1v1
so it's like you know Pokemon
and then you know the kids in high
school used to beat up we're those kids
oh yeah yeah I don't even know
is that like a magic card reference a
little bit similar that Games Workshop
it's the stuff they're playing on the
upstairs level yeah right uh so I was
yeah I was just playing the online
version of that and every time I went to
class I just I didn't care I I slept and
then when they made me do uh
architecture [__] online I just play
Yu-Gi-Oh so and naturally I I went to a
pretty
decent College uh just didn't really I
didn't want to major in in that they're
just going through the motion yeah going
through the motions
um for for most up until like 18 19 and
and then that's when I started reading
like books like self-help books
um would you say you were like in a
depressed place oh I was in a very bad
place yeah yeah oh wow you're in high
school still or you graduated so I I
graduated high school all throughout
High School I was I was I was you know
just going to school coming back and
watching anime playing video games and
and it was just that cycle
uh up until college is it was still a
little bit of that but then I went to I
went to an acting class right after
class my freshman year that that was
like completely out of that wasn't part
of my Genesis that wasn't anything so it
was just so out of my comfort zone but
it took me
it it really pushed me to just uh live
life a little bit more what made you
want to join an acting class
ah it's a good question I I feel like
because I watched a lot of YouTube
growing up I don't know it was just
something you just wanted to try it yeah
I just wanted to unlock something in me
I feel like maybe there is some
something were you inspired by like
Uncle Sam Uncle Chad
I take Serious acting classes
that's so funny if kids watch that [__]
back then and they're like I can't wait
to be a refugee
I can't wait to act like an old Refugee
were you like more shy like before that
yeah I was very shy I was very uh had a
lot of social anxiety had a lot of
pretty pretty introverted in in high
school
um but that acting class along with the
books along with working out it like
slowly in college I started uh glowing
up oh cool yeah yeah if I showed you a
picture of like when I was 18 19 it it
was bad like it looked like it looked
like I I stayed in it I've seen some
like before photos yeah yeah yeah I
think you posted one or something yeah
yeah yeah but it's funny because you
come off so like confident and like
charismatic it's funny to imagine like
right now after the the Italian sex have
her yeah yeah a true sex average true
sex habit oh there it is yeah yeah you
guys are you guys are reflecting each
other what I did is that what it is he
does kind of remind uh me of you because
I was a [__] loser in high school as
well he didn't say he was a loser yeah
yeah yeah he's like whoa whoa Whoa
saying about me you know he didn't say
that no no if I saw my high school
himself I slapped his ass and he also
said he was smart he was an architecture
no I don't think you were smart we're
just trying to draw a line between him
I was forced yo they kind of look like
they could be brothers though with the
hair and then the dangly necklace and
you guys you guys dress cool and [__]
dude that's the cool side yeah that is
the cool side I mean but we had to come
from something very not C double o l c
double o l baby
yeah oh so when did you start making
YouTube videos or content in general I
think it was around 20 like late 2016.
how did you make the first one the first
video uh
it was unlisted it was it was unlisted
now but
um were you embarrassed oh no it just
didn't fit my vibe because around that
time recovering a rap song that had the
end
[Music]
I'm just yeah I think I think those were
like were in group chats though yeah but
but
um now I think I was a little bit
inspired by like because I I grew up in
New York so around that time there was a
there was a Facebook page called humans
in New York yeah well I remember oh I
love that page yeah yeah yeah so I was
like huh this is going viral why don't I
just ask people
stories in like a video version of it
right a video version uh it sucked ass
yeah just yeah it was it was uh it was
just shot so far the mic sucked and it
was
I mean it was up for like two three
years but then looking back on it now
I'm like yo this isn't me
not that I don't care but yeah I don't
care
joking around
something that was successful and you're
like let me try to replicate it versus
who am I right right exactly and
according to this six years ago your
first viral videos would you blow your
professor for an a that that's a good
question
that's me that's a burning question it's
me right there
probably haven't thought of that in a
while yeah and the answer is yes you
would and then so when your parents see
that what are your parents do they go oh
good job man no they didn't even see it
they didn't even see that one the one
that they saw first was the ass whooping
video oh they didn't see the would you
suck a dick for a million dollars uh
they probably saw it afterwards but the
first one was when the the ass woman
video got shared to them by like one of
their friends because I was I was kind
of like exposing myself I was like yo my
dad had the hands from the gods like he
he came down on me with lightning and it
was just
yeah and basically everybody in the
comments were like yeah you know I
relate to that I don't know a lot of
love but then my parents did they watch
the video and go you lying you know we
[__] you up harder than this [__] you
made me look soft
I show you lightning
but but they didn't want that like stuff
to be out there to be you know talking
about you know family trauma on on the
internet yeah so okay like they're like
we're not the only Asian family that
gets beat down come on man like
there's so many but but when they called
me up to to tell me like oh what are you
doing I hung up on them oh wow yeah I
was in college at the time and you panic
huh do you panic no I think at that time
I was already like I knew just the the
the
like where the conversation's gonna go
oh yeah exactly like the the negative
you dishonor the family you stupid son
of a [__] I guess I'm gonna keep doing
it
but I just knew like that how that how
negative that mentality was yeah just
just growing I read this book called
Rich Dad Poor Dad yeah
yeah that that kind of opened my mind up
about just the the teachings of like
traditional Asian parents and just how
Nick I was also just starting to become
aware of my thoughts and what other
people's thoughts can do to me oh so so
just being aware of that I I didn't even
want to associate any of my parents
thoughts and and teachings like it's
gonna poison you exactly exactly that's
what a great foresight right there man
and you so so just it it became a little
disrespectful at one point when they
would call me I hung I hang up they keep
calling I blocked them it's kind of
disrespectful a little bit a little bit
gotta do it but I think it was it was
very because a lot of Asian parents or a
lot of Asian kids they they would
probably sit down with their parents and
get their ass bait yeah yeah you know
and just try to have a conversation with
them but it's like I can't reason with
them sometimes you can't you can't you
can't you can't you're talking to wall
you know the lucky Asian kids that have
parents that have reasoning skills they
can have conversations but most of us
they don't know what reasoning is I
never heard of that no they just
[Laughter]
I never heard of talking with your
parents about that because it's like you
can't tell them they're wrong yeah
they're a buzzfeed article that's 10
ways why you're stupid
[__]